how you doing today sir I'm good I'm
good how are you I'm doing good listen I
really want to start with a sincere
congrats on your short because I don't
think people really realize making a
short film is like next to Impossible
because you have to accomplish so much
in such a short period of time so I'm
curious when you were thinking about
directing and writing and doing
something like this was it almost like a
feature might be easier absolutely well
I think I definitely figured that out as
soon as we got into production a feature
would in a lot of ways be easier from a
really kind of practical side people
don't want to give money to something
that isn't doesn't have a clear return
on investment and and on the creative
side too cinematographers or actors you
know are like why would I you know do
this instead of keep my schedule open
for something else so it's really For
the Love of the Game and then especially
when you're trying to make something
that's a bit larger uh as a short you
know um so from the Practical side it's
fairly insane and and sort of dumb but
it was really gratifying and I just felt
you know I wrote this piece and I just
felt like it wanted to be made and I
wanted to make it and I felt that um I I
experimented with what it would be as a
feature it didn't feel right to have it
be a feature I just wanted to sort of be
this short story and um and then I you
know am really really happy and I got
very lucky with being able to make it
and learned a lot so now that I'm
working I'm working now on what will be
the first feature which is an entirely
different story but I've been through
the entire process on a scale that's
sort of closer to like a micr budget
feature and know the lay of the land a
little bit more and feel more confidence
in going into that kind of world so for
people uh when are people going to be
able to see it because I'm sure they'll
be we're gonna you know what I mean well
what I want to do is we're doing the
whole festival run now and then what I
want to do is release it as a film so
you know like in music they'll release a
single sometimes with some of the same
Pomp and Circumstance that they'll
release an album at this point and in
this world like these divisions of of of
and how it doesn't really matter you
know certainly in a streaming universe
so um so my goal is to continue to do
the circuit that we're on now and then
explore distribution and figure out you
know what the best home for it is and
really release it and do more press like
this and and get people to see it but
that'll probably there's rules around
you can't have it available online until
you get you know you there stuff that I
don't entirely understand but it won't
be available until we sort of uh do the
whole circuit so I hate saying this uh
but no one has seen the film yet and how
have you been describing it to like
friends and family I describe it it's a
it's a film about the older brother of
this young movie star who's a musician
who's failed in his career so far who's
having a really hard time and his down
and out coming back to the family home
on the day of his younger brother's
movie premiere kind of break and he's
back channeling with the paparazzi to
steal the younger brother's computer and
sell it to them but it's that's the plot
what it's kind of emotionally about is
the relationships between people who
love each other when success and ego get
in the way sure one of the things that
the short does really well is build up
tension very quick and um I'm curious
how much did you realize were you going
for that for that kind kind of tension
and what was it like in the editing room
when you have such a short period of
time to establish emotions like this
it's very challenging and what I learned
in the editing room is actually that
less was more in terms of this piece
when it came time to the
emotional um material it was easier to
like lose some of the detail and some of
the content inside the
scenes helped the actual emotional
subtext of what was happening land even
more strongly and then when it comes to
the tension I have kind of a
pet thing about you know I love
character driven movies that's my whole
bag you know it's like movies about
human beings that's really what I'm
where my passion is and I feel strongly
that with the audiences today and the
attention spans that exist it's it it's
it's the it
impels storytellers who want to make
character-driven films dramas you know
to get better at storytelling that grabs
people you know
um often it can kind of feel like this
polarized thing where there's
character-driven movies that are require
a lot of patience and require a lot of
you know sort of people who are already
interested in that thing or you go to a
genre you know and you you work in along
these rails which can be wonderful but
the the movie that I've grew up loving
um really and I think even more so we
just need to find a way storytellers who
want to tell things about people I think
there's a way to do that without sort of
Trojan horsing it into a genre if you
just get really on top of um great
storytelling structure and compelling
narrative and um and things that feel
like real to people so I'm learning what
that process is in that craft but that's
where having this be a very tense piece
comes in and having you want to know
what's going to happen next so one of
the things is I think it's about 15
minutes how much did you debate the
runtime in terms of like no did you were
you aiming at 15 were you thinking maybe
I want to be nine or 10 minutes like how
did you figure that out the original
script was 28 pages and I was I was
living in a world of this is gonna be a
30 minute film and I'm gonna have to
just e again it's like making a short a
big scale it's dumb but I was like this
is what the movie wants to be this is
what I have to do it makes it it's
totally impractical when it comes to
trying to get into festivals and doing
stuff like that um
and then in the edit we just found that
it wasn't it was like everyone was like
God if you could get it more toward 15
it'd be so much easier to submit it and
it's so much easier to send out and it'
be so great and I was like great happy
to hear that but it's not going to
happen happen and then the editor this
is why it's great to have great
editors um not with that in mind but
just for the purposes of making the
story work found you know a whole host
of things that to cut that I would have
never imagined being okay with cutting
but they brought they brought the the
the essence of the story out even more
yeah it's so funny so did you feel like
you were killing Darlings or did you
feel like oh actually yeah this can just
go there was one where I watched it and
I was like if this editor had told me he
was going to cut this it was a whole SE
dialogue section I would be like this
isn't the guy for me you know I'm not
going to hire him and when he did it and
I watched it I went that
he's right you know he was totally right
and and it it it made the movie work and
it was just you know it was a great um
great learning experience I wrote the
film originally as a Warner and so and
then I was going crazy all in all in
yeah it was nuts but I was luckily
talked out of that strongly I also
fought that and then obviously that was
the best thing that ever happened but
you know the the flow of It kind of
stayed you know the sense that you're
stuck with this guy moving through this
space fairly in real time yeah so a lot
of people debate espe I mean you're
you're uh a lot of people debate what
they're going to do as an actor for
their first feature short whatever
they're going to direct for the first
time so how much did you debate what the
material was going to be in terms of the
subject matter for my first effort and
uh you know was it almost something else
sure I mean I'm always working on a lot
of different pieces you know between
acting work or even while I'm doing
acting work I'm developing a lot of
different stories and what I'm always
looking for is the thing that there's
just kind of a magic little click that
sometimes happens happens where
intuitively go now this is the one other
ones may be tempting they may seem even
easier but this is the one and I just
have to see that out I mean that's my
process right now with the first feature
that I'm writing or not the first
feature I'm writing but the feature that
I'm writing that I'd like to be the
first one I
make it's very challenging it takes a
long time but I just intuitively sense
that this is the one and it was the same
with this piece it just was like other
things might even make more sense
another feature like we talked about
might make more sense but there's an
emotional resonance and there's just a
way in which there's sort of a there
there there's kind of a you feel like
these people there's a world and when
you have to it's very useful because
when you sit down with the hair and
makeup department and they say what do
the people you know look like you can
kind of almost ask the world that seems
to almost exist as opposed you know and
that and when you know that's there it
kind of can carry you through what is
this incredibly labor intensive process
of making something bring something into
life you had you've worked with a lot of
talented directors I mean a lot uh and
I'm sure that the whole time you were
studying them looking at lenses because
you obviously knew you wanted to do
something like this so what were some of
the big lessons you took away from the
directors you've worked with the really
gifted directors that you're like this
I'm stealing this and I'm stealing this
I mean I have like notes on my phone and
it'll be it'll be dirting and then
parenthesis and whatever the movie is
and and it will be just you know pages
and pages of all the notes that I'm
taking as an actor some a lot of them
are DOs a lot of them are don'ts you
know and it's can be really micro things
you know um but I think that my first
film was for Franc for
Copa um he did a
really um he really emphasized the
rehearsal process process and in that
rehearsal process we were experimenting
we were making fools out of ourselves we
were he was he he understood on a deep
level that actors needed
to um play and needed to have fun and
needed to feel that they could make
mistakes and feel safe and so he
facilitated this rehearsal process that
yes helped us figure out where the scene
wanted to be and practical things but
mainly it made us feel like a troop and
it made it feel like the joy of being in
a play in middle school and that is um
really translates to the films for all
his the seriousness and the gravitas of
his films at the heart of it are these
Great Performances and that comes more
quickly out of that than it does out of
you know these other environments so
rehearsal being really really Paramount
to to me and then you know just about a
you know hundreds of thousands of others
um things I feel like I've picked up
from all these people I've been so
fortunate to be able to work for
speaking of Copa I see his name as an
executive producer on the short uh can
you talk about how he got involved and
what exactly he did to help facilitate
the project yeah I sent it to him I sent
the script to him and he was very
supportive of it um he
obviously Define like really lit the
spark of inspiration for me when I was
17 18 uh
and and I wanted to do film making then
I went up and interviewed him about film
making and he sat and just kind of this
was like 10 years after I'd done Tetra
my first movie and he was so generous as
always with his thoughts and insights
around all of that and then he's watched
the film a couple times and given me his
Impressions and that was mainly it it
was it was more of an honorific than
anything else and means a lot that he
you know um did that for me it's very
nice yeah uh there's a lot of people
that I would be scared to show my movie
to and he would probably be at the top
of the list so I yeah he's definitely up
there I spent the last week sending it
off to these it's it's it's like
ludicrous like the directors you know
that I'm setting this film to it's very
funny um but is also you know nice it's
like uh saying hey you know yeah it's
like being a kid showing up to a family
reunion or something and you've grown up
and you're going hey I'm an adult yeah I
I mean also you're basically it's like
you know you're calling card to a
different Club you know it's uh it's
it's completely different thing so one
of the things in the film is you there's
a there's a black mail situation with
your brother's character and I'm just
curious the the amount of money you're
being offered is
$80,000 is that based on a on a real
number or is that just like making it up
as like maybe that's what they pi
no I you know I'm I'm very research
driven in everything and so I had a
conversation with someone who worked in
that sort of world making those deals in
the paparazzi sort of back end side of
those things and talk to him about what
the real numbers would be and that's
definitely on the high end but it's not
out of the realm of possibility for
really big star and for some real juicy
stuff that could that could be it and I
wanted to make it a number you know Cole
needs $6,000 from his brother and I
wanted it to make it a number where we
felt not that we wanted him to do it but
that we understood the magnitude of it
you know it's not like he's just it's
it's not get the money from your brother
get the money from there it's get the
money from your brother or get so much
more money that would change your whole
life um yeah it's interesting to see how
many numbers and figures play on screen
with audiences you really feel the
amount of you know when somebody says an
amount of money in a movie you really
feel that in the room it's interesting
well the other thing is that like
oftentimes in movies uh they're dealing
with millions of dollars and or you know
end of the world and it's like because
character thing you know it's $80,000
it's not a a sub it's not such a crazy
number but for him life changing
absolutely yeah exactly um so talk a
little bit about how you got the title
and did you ever debate uh with another
title like a one word you know what I
mean because the title's everything yeah
I always loved it I it functions it's
more poetic to me than anything else you
know I like that it almost sounds like
Sunday Bloody Sunday I like that it you
know um there was a uh there's like a
myth uh I think it has it's some maybe
it's a Grim's fairy tale or something
about the snake brother or
yeah something like that that I had
listened to that I only retroactively
realized had influenced this but it was
about you know a brother who gets thrown
out the window when he's born and turns
into a snake and then the younger
brother you know is brought into the
house and then the younger brother's
going to get married and this this giant
snake shows up and says me before him
and um and so I I mainly like function I
like I mainly like titles that work on
kind of a poetic basis I think that they
add like a fe Reservoir Dogs being
always a great one to me you know like
that doesn't mean anything in the
context of the film but it adds this
this intangible quality to it so you
shot on film and you worked with Ben
Mullen as your DP I'm curious how much
did you debate film versus just using a
red camera and saying we're GNA do it
digitally it was always you know that in
the rehearsal were always the big ticket
items that I was were non-negotiable for
me you know um there was a world of
maybe shooting 16 you know there was
kind of I wanted to shoot 35 anamorphic
and so we shot 35 spherical um and like
it's interesting I would that's like
something I'm really curious about I
want to do some more tests with 16
because it's interesting that
that there's a whole technical side of
this but it's interesting to see what
they actually with the color
process what those differences are
because they're such Advanced color
technology now um but more more
interestingly film to me you feel you
feel the emotions of a film more when
it's shot on film it's a physical
process you're seeing the human beings
you're feeling the textures of the film
and that was everything in this and it
just wakes me up when I see something
that's shot on film um and then I had
worked with Christopher Nolan like right
before I shot this and I was like if I
don't do it now you know if for some
reason I don't shoot on film now I'll be
you know disinvited from the uh the the
the premiere party so it was um it
was uh yeah just is just love it I love
what it brings to things and in an era
where we're all seeing a thousand
digital images all day it brings back a
little of that old magic that film felt
like when I was younger I understand
digital um I understand the need for it
and I do think also a lot of people just
don't or or um when you're shooting with
no light and you like I look at what um
uh Gareth Edwards did with the Creator
and they used like a Best Buy camera
that cost three grand to shoot at night
with like a little LED and they were
able to shoot like a pitch black
darkness and and obviously that's
incredible but but that's a specific
thing that you're going for and the
aesthetic of film is it's incredible but
again you couldn't if you were shooting
at night you were not it would be a
different thing it'd be a totally
different thing and I do I really I do
feel that there are fil you know
Tangerine is more interesting for it
being shot on the iPhone like there are
places where that's in its own aesthetic
but I think it's about owning that
aesthetic and the thing that drives me
crazy is seeing all these films that are
now shot on on with digital cameras but
are being lit like it's
1993 and you're looking at these actors
in a Bookshop and it's like the
they're it's like you can see the light
it's like
so heavy-handed and it's so fake
especially character-driven movies and
um so I just think like you know the
lighting
practices uh you know there's just still
a lot of like well we do this now and
it's like no you don't need anything you
get the these cameras are so sharp if
you just put them in the room like get
the Reel you know let's why are we
outing things you know so anyway if you
look at some I was just having this
conversation with someone if you look at
like early 990s or mid 90s romantic
comedies or some of those movies that
are like some that are not even that
good they're shot better than other
movies oh absolutely absolutely bananas
they look gorgeous yeah and and then you
get things and you have all these people
coming together and and I think a big
challenge for for for me at least as a
filmmaker and I feel this more when I'm
the actor and I don't have this say so
is getting people to do less you know
applies M that applies in a huge way to
acting but it also applies to I had a
great hair and makeup team Jackie Nolton
and Lori gidro who were like if somebody
shows up and their hair looks good let's
what are we doing let's not with it
or if somebody if we go into a room and
there's light coming in the window how
much do we really need to add to that
and being able to exercise that
restraint and not do the well I'm being
paid so I better do my job and then you
just get these films that end up feeling
like bad TV movies or something so
anyway yeah no it's interesting I don't
think of it that's that's a different
perspective uh you're coming from a
different perspective but anyway um I am
curious you're writing a feature right
now um can you tease anything or is it
like are you just going to be like I'm
writing a feature the all I could say
really is that it's thematically and
tonally sort of along some of the same
lines you know Show Business and family
is very Central to it um I would say the
comedy of it is bigger and the drama of
it is darker so the the colors are all
the same but they're a little more
heightened in both directions and other
than that I'm just you know in a cave
wrestling with making this thing happen
it's really
a fascinating process that's you know I
I totally get it one of the things
though truth when nowadays with like a
talking drama you need to make sure what
people are talking about is stuff that's
like
interesting like uh I know this sounds
you know it's easier to to have get
people watch when they say oh it's a
story about these three actors in
Hollywood and it somehow incorporates
the movie I don't know maybe I'm I'm I'm
wrong about this but I think you know
it's like one of the reasons I think
Pulp Fiction besides the movie is
incredible you're dealing with these you
know gangsters and characters that you
want to spend time with yes absolutely
absolutely I go by I I go by the same
idea I think from a slightly different
road which is when I'm working on
something I want to feel that it's
almost um maximalist in its in in the
world that you're in that the world
you're in is detailed enough where you
feel like you could walk into it and
there would actually be something on
that counter and everything everybody
talks about is really based on something
that those characters would say in that
moment and are part of their environment
in that way you know and actors are
often you know so much of the job is
filling in the environment that you're
playing in and getting into well you
know what's this time period what would
people be wearing how would who would
their Heroes be whatever the case may be
and so from a writing
perspective things feel more alive when
they've been lived in in this in in at
this level of depth and you can kind of
feel it I think on a different level so
that's the aspiration it takes a lot of
work and a lot of time I just watched
documentary about Robert Caro who wrote
the um Lynden Johnson biographies and he
would go to he would go to the South and
live where lynon Johnson lived so that
he could bring that to life with Rich
Vivid detail and I think that everybody
given that every part of life and every
human being given that level of
attention and detail becomes Vivid and
fascinating I think so um that's what
I'm that's the standard I'm trying to
hold myself to to my own chin
um we are hopefully approaching the end
of the actor strike God willing it's
today or soon what has it been like for
you the last few months and are you just
like dying to to work again you know I
have a lot of I'm very fortunate it's
been very sad it's very sad to be in
this city it's very sad to see
restaurants closed it's very sad to talk
to people who are out of work and are um
and for whom this has stalled you know
there's a lot of people who
were you know like I'm I'm I'm very
lucky and I had a few movies come out
this year during this time and I have a
movie I'm gon to do after this and it's
kind of a uh has has stalled things but
it hasn't killed things and there's a
lot of people for whom this has maybe
meant that this isn't the career they
can have anymore not to mention the um
the other Industries in Los Angeles in
particular that are dependent on this
entertainment industry I mean you know
um so it's it's been that kind of heavy
feeling of stalled not nearly as bad as
covid but almost a little reminiscent of
those times where things are in this
holding pattern we're all waiting for
this thing um and uh you know but I'm
I'm really glad these conversations are
being had now because if not now then
than when and um and so for me it's been
you know that and then I've been trying
to take advantage of the opportunity to
write and develop um as much as I can
and um and do my uh I have a theater
space that's where I'm at right now that
I'm putting together to start doing
plays and then uh events basically
you've been using all the time for other
things yeah I haven't been using it as
much during the pandemic like publicly
but I'm I'm setting it up and we're
doing some of the the the things all the
logistics of getting it set up so we can
start do our first play
next year here I'll show you this is the
building you're on substation in Cypress
Park so we're getting that together to
start as kind of an Off Broadway house
style theater um in LA and then have you
know a series of dinners movie Nights
little concerts lectures things like
that in between a that sounds awesome B
bringing more culture to La uh thumbs up
and obviously when you start doing this
please let me know so I can help you
promote um absolutely thank you and I do
want to ask you one thing I read of
course this could be wrong that when you
were much younger uh basically Stephen
Spielberg was the one who sort of helped
you get noticed like slash and so what
exact can you sort of for people that
don't know can you sort of share that
story sure I uh was making little movies
with my friends on the weekends and like
the kind of thing that would be put on
YouTube now you know in a silly way and
I made one that was shown at a girl uh
that I was friends with spot Mitzvah and
it was on a little screen uh on the side
it wasn't even really screened it was
just like on a loop somewhere um and
this girl was friends with Steph
Spielberg's daughter and
Stephen I was 14 Stephen was at the bot
Mitzvah as a result and saw me on this
little video and thought that I was
funny and um uh we got a call from
Dreamworks you know my mom and I uh like
a week or so later and brought in to
meet Leslie Feldman who's still a really
close friend at dinner with her last
week um uh to have a
meeting uh about my being an actor and
and so he um you know did this and and
as a result I was able to get an agent
and it started my entire career which
was just you know
an amazing thing for him to do I don't I
guess I have to ask you so what do you
get him for his birthday every year for
changing your
life well now I now I am really
questioning my decisions I've never got
him anything um I'm not really close
with him I I've only
talked I'm teasing but you're right I
should certainly I've written him
letters and stuff in the past you know
thanking him as an adult I talked to him
uh he amlin produced A Brave New World
which was a series I did a few years ago
and I thanked him around that time but
you're you're smart I should get
something I mean it it can't hurt to
send him a card because he has all the
money like there's nothing you can buy
him that he can't buy himself true right
I think it's the personal thing like a
personal note or a personal card yeah
you know that that basically says thank
you for changing my life yeah exactly
that I've done that I have sent to him
I'm sending him a note today actually
because I sent him Shadow brother Sunday
uh by the way no pressure changed my
life maybe you have 15 minutes exactly
exactly you know um so I'm basically
done but um who did you actually trust
for honest feedback when before you
locked the movie great question you know
what I mean great question yeah well
especially because I'm acting in it um
exactly I was at Pixar I was at Pixar a
few years back and kind of got a a tour
and their process and I've always
believed in this but it was that was
very inspirational for this too that and
I I have basically a Brain Trust of
about 10 to 12 people that I check in
with at every step of every process you
know growing
up in the inspiration of of
Copa you know you think about him and
Spielberg and Scorsese and dama and that
George Lucas this group
it's not like six Geniuses walked into a
room and happened to meet each other
they made each other better they pushed
each other they're thinking their
conversations uh briano has this I think
it's called senius this idea that it's
like genius through a scene of people
and so I really leaned on these 12
people it's a combination of writers and
some actors and
directors for the script and then what
we did was had a table read at at this
space at hon with a bunch of really good
actors and we recorded the table read
and I had friends of mine come listen to
that table read then we sat in the back
here and they gave me notes on it then
we took the table read and I drew
storyboards and did an animatic
basically the way Pixar does where it's
an animated version of the movie with
the storyboards with the table read
underneath it so it's a really crude
animated version of the whole film
screened it here with the same group sat
out in the back had them beat the ship
out of me on all the notes of what they
thought should be different with that um
so by the time I'm filming we've Road
tested the film as much as humanly
possible because that seemed to be the
key to Pixar's incredible batting
average was you can test things before
you're just on most movies you write a
thing then you're on set and everybody
you're hemorrhaging money and you're
just hoping it works and so that level
of preparation was really useful I got
some of that inspiration from the cone
brothers who storyboard extensively and
you know when you show up on set you
have in your trailer the storyboards
so then I edited the film and did a
screening of it another group of people
gave me notes on it um and then sending
it out to people so very fortunate to
have that community of people and it was
so instrumental and make like if you saw
the version of the movie that it started
as as opposed to where it got it was
made an enormous difference yeah this is
this explains why I how why I am enjoyed
this short so much because you spent an
a crazy amount of time like you know um
rehearsing every aspect of this thing
you know yeah exactly exactly most
people just I've spoken to an awful lot
of people in Hollywood most people do
not spend this much time uh fine-tuning
something yeah I it's just my you know
somewhat temperament somewhat of belief
system and then when we did the film we
did four days of rehearsal me and Nick
Robinson where we
and Lisa edstein was there for most of
it too and then Nick cersi came in at
the end we did like improvisations of
our childhood you know moments where I'm
the old where where I'm 15 and he's 12
and I'm showing him my music and talking
about how I'm going to be a famous
musician or he's calling me from Camp
because he's scared or the day our dad
fell off the wagon and our mom's trying
to hide it from us and we did all these
improvisations to try to get the feeling
in our bones of what this family is Liv
lived through so that it would speak
with a sort of different resonance when
we talked in inside the film itself I
could ask you a million other things but
I'm going to stop there and say uh
really congratulations and I'm really
looking forward to being your feature
and uh I hope people can watch the short
soon thank you so much good to see
you